[Music]
all right here we go
yeah
[Music]
and then go to comments in community oh
and then next to the user you want to
make a moderator click the flag icon and
then select let's you wait in my life I
can't see from live here I'm go I'm
going on it should say oh yeah there you
I got a refresh boom there it is
testing one two three we're playing
destiny no I the destiny music is loud
as [ __ ]
alright I think if you click on my name
I just typed in chat I see you ah there
you go boom done yeah as soon as I come
off 43 people 47 I mean it's like this
is what I'm talking about guys huh he's
a podcast yeah just you two I didn't do
Twitter seconds host yours you give it
I'm saying
[Music]
Oh
I love the destiny music too much too
much yeah yeah I've been around town
before way back yeah way back in the day
like when he was like blowing up he did
a it was on the Tom Green show but he
did a comedy spot where it was like a
drop in and like the audience and
everybody was all excited and he just
gets on the mic and starts making noises
and like he starts pissing everybody
turn the lights off dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious oh my god years ago the game
title on the video and it won't stay I
don't understand this
I see indium our old friend assume or
gambit yes yeah but I don't know why
it's not you go you guys gonna play
gambit yeah
wait I got to go to the old creator
studio I don't like this new creator
studio on YouTube I I don't like it it's
like they moved everything I just don't
like how it looks
yeah I don't like oh oh there we go
yeah so Steve Steve punk-ass
acknowledged done doesn't respond oh my
god
all right let's do this he probably
probably thinks someone to talk to him
oh my just destiny music oh it feels
good to play again I know but now we're
gonna get sucked in we're gonna get
sucked into destiny get your worst fire
team jerseys right there where's fire
team jersey everybody see it yeah that's
true
Almighty turn the music off is gonna
annoy the [ __ ] out of me it's so loud
psycho well coke was involved for sure I
mean that's all you do you that's just
it doesn't matter what it is you're
involved there's something negative
going on there's like a fight yeah for
sure cokes involved in that guy's voice
now I was like you know I told them I
told them my and we were in we're at a
bar so like it was already loud so and
we ended cordial everything was fine and
then he started getting like he was fine
with me but then I guess he told Craig
like if coke tries to come over here and
beat me up I'm gonna call the cops you
know what the problem is everybody's get
everybody's got to stop talking about
everybody else behind their back that's
the problem worse fire teams have and I
notice I'm noticing yeah you know
Oh God just this is what I'm talking
about right now we gotta get you got to
get into the ring already so you could
like get all this pent-up nonsense out
on somebody else
tired of it I gotta get a new mic there
we go I gotta go to Mike's - okay well
I'm here Wow
I don't even know what to do anymore
with destiny Jesus okay I guess I gotta
go to the tower no he didn't of course
he didn't he told me later he was like
no cuz he was I was on his podcast he
was talking about you have to play this
I'm gonna buy it for you and I was like
okay if you buy it for me I'll play it
and he never did that was just for the
fans
he's like a politician he says he's
gonna do something and he doesn't do it
he's like oh I'm gonna do it bro well
we're back to destiny here we are
destiny back again the boys back in town
[Music]
tone Bell is gonna be on this week tone
Bell I got you actually have to finish
editing that episode tonight so I so I
gotta do this for like an hour then I
got to work I got to do it to get it out
in the morning tone Bell from what show
was he on from the show fam I think it's
on is it NBC's either NBC or CBS one of
those but good old tone but you just had
our special out funny dude we have a
great talk about
the business so get involved like whoa
I'm gonna have Steve on bio me wait I'm
still coming to the tower God relax
impatient ass [ __ ]
hey what's up we're not starting
I don't want to I don't want to hear my
brothers I don't want to hear my pika TV
[Laughter]
yeah you said it yeah oh my god no do
not come on my channel and say hi piece
of [ __ ] damn
here we go with Dustin I should share
this go fast all right do we have to get
to the gambit Bounty's is that what I
should do oh my god I forgot yeah this
game dude I haven't please this game is
a long I don't even know what I'm doing
oh just this this just we're gonna find
out this is still the best in terms of
my gameplay really anthems fun though
man I gotta say me I've been playing
that it's pretty it's a smooth game man
when you're playing I especially like
the free play the free play mechanics
you know what you're really able to do
in there like people aren't impressed
with it yeah there's not enough stuff
going on I agree there's not enough
anymore to do yeah it's so stupid when
you go okay I'm ready to go when you
guys want to leave
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah let's go did I leave
yes I think I think I got returned to
orbit for being inactive
what never being a dick what doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense well you weren't
inactive Jesus I was moving around
enough I sent me some meaning send you
some black Spencer I'm back there we go
there's three of us there you are
are we still this fake squirrel squad
what is it squirtle it it's not even
squirrel anymore what is that squirrel
it it's so what is that squirrel it
squirtle squirtle squirtle oh my god
it's so stupid
as he coming in there he is what are we
playing gambit
yeah I just got my breakneck I don't
know if you finish then got it it's
driving breakneck what is that is it
another mission oh I've been here - it
finical it's the pinnacle weapon for
playing gambit oh I like hazard of the
cast like upgraded hazard of the cast I
didn't like it what should I put on a no
me what a rampage rampage is the best
fur for for auto rifles because you know
so weak sim I said it was never squirrel
squad could be backup will show you what
weapons should I use the mag my main
ingredient and let me get my black tile
if you have I would put targeting but if
you have the rampage spec do that one
because it makes rampage last longer or
do I want I don't know you know what I'm
gonna use my okay I'm ready how we
started okay yep we're flying in Mike oh
my god
okay okay Pikachu for sure knows who
this brother is because you just put
pika TV five times in my chat pick a TV
will never be a thing that is not a
station gonna be offered on Comcast
comcast cable okay
that's you know what's funny is for our
next sketch for our show when we get
picked up we actually we will have
something called pica TV that'll be
funny it's all but it's all like it's
all it's all short stuff though you know
I mean like it's all like living in a
tiny house you know a little bit all the
schedules are like how he can't ride
rollercoasters
[Laughter]
sounds good
can everybody hear the other guys good I
want to make sure hey can you make sure
they're my my it's synced up to set my
sound with the video you sure that's
synced up because sometimes it gets
[ __ ] up and I just don't know what to
do about it
just look yeah I guess I could I can
look at it I got I got a [ __ ] thing
right here oh it works it works it works
I just checked it we are synched earth I
think what happens is when I change the
screen like my different screens that's
when it gets messed up
Karen Bert so this is gambit everybody
who doesn't play destiny it's pretty fun
sometimes
oh sorry you can't it's gonna be dope is
this because a new kids single it's
single like it's one round that's it oh
I can't believe we're playing this again
I cannot believe it
I know but it's just destiny is like
that that girlfriend that just put it on
you good you can't get it rid of it you
know I mean you're just like oh here she
is a game with a like destiny good yeah
we could put it in Destiny's booty you
know me just need let us do all that
nasty stuff oh yeah if you want to send
a riff on with Griffin theme song send
it to my email Eric at Eric Griffin calm
but make sure you label it your name
people been sending like the same title
for every single one
everyone says Reverend with Griffin and
I need people to send their name so I
can um you know cuz I'm going to my next
solo episode I'm gonna go through all
the theme songs I'm gonna play all of
them but I'm gonna have two mics I'm of
a singing mic and the talking mic so I
got some really great theme songs so I
want to play all of them so everybody
can we can all vote which ones are the
best and I have a poll up and everything
I did this one this one funky when I use
twice I used on another episodes it was
so good get your [ __ ] together man hey
losing motes already yeah oh here we go
there it is you know it always comes
with an excuse you know I mean it's
never like you did something bad you
just say well and it wasn't for small
block out there are gonna change - yeah
Wow let me know brothers in here we're
gonna get Steve back on guys I'm gonna
get Steve's gonna start playing too and
he's gonna play on this chain is he is I
know how to do I know how to make this
work don't worry he doesn't realize like
this YouTube is the thing man
I mean twitch is just I'm the over
twitch you know I mean YouTube has
everything to a Chaz and more to summon
a primeval I don't like too heavy on
twitch on on on gambit though you know
to me that's like you should get more
heavy don't you think or it's probably
already we definitely already ridiculous
I guess there's some heavy as I say it
here yeah yeah do we're balling right
now does Griffin's here
ah
I'm making all kind of orbs over here
well this [ __ ] here he's coming from
the other side
I'm Keynes it's coming from caves you
can tell by the let's go let's go let's
go Joe Dennis go let's go let's go let's
go let's go this is my [ __ ] right here
is this barricade the barricade to
reload your weapons I don't know why you
would not use this this is the only one
you should use you know I mean I'm
[ __ ] this primeval oh man I just got
oh my god this piece of [ __ ] guy
if they start melting doot people melt
their prime even I don't know how like
what are they using have you ever just
played against a team where it's just
like this is like better alright this is
going down real fast
you know we don't win this I swear to
God
there we go I know that have been a
nightmare where those orbs nobody made
orbs
yes primeval wait I gotta fix something
I might thing we will not accept any
slander towards Steve in the chat stop
Dan wait is that just what is that a
cool oh yeah we got rid of you do we've
hit a vote we just voted Oh Greg you
missed a vote Oh Greg no not Craig we
don't want Craig to go not Craig
let me know what day your free cuz I'll
bring dogs down wait we're gonna be
doing the making the Griffin the Griffin
studio experience
yeah but he's down to come by so just
let me know what day this week okay I'll
be good all right I'm leaving Friday so
you were playing we're back to destiny
bro
get with the program dude destinies back
brah
destiny I swear to God the second
account do they call you sick boy is
that we you have to change your name to
sick boy you have to you have to be
thick boy from now on we I'm changing
your I'm putting that in my phone you're
now thick boy in my phone we have to
have a poll we have to put a poll up TDF
rose or thick book I think I'm really
liking thick boy that's what I'm saying
big boy is thank you everybody that's in
the chat right now of thanks for
watching this is me and worst fire team
you can also see want you playing on
worst fire team but we are playing
destiny today it's a destiny type of
night and thanks for being involved
apparently just what are they doing on
Tuesday they change in
good new gun I let me in this next
cruise don't do crucible hey you know I
hate [ __ ] crucible no we're gonna win
this oh I like that even better cabo
name [ __ ] no no how about this general
titty fig boy general city chick boy
general titty sick boy to the rescue
[Laughter]
oh my god I can't believe I just felt
like that did you see that oh god damn
it man
just gain I just [ __ ] fell so stupid
because he needs exercise
dude have you guys noticed in your
neighbor in your neighborhood in LA like
I me Pikachu I'm not you get nobody
Zanetti but Craig Craig do they have
bikes all over your [ __ ] neighborhood
right now and Steady's scooters dude
there's freaking bikes everywhere now
[ __ ] is so annoying and I show you my
bike if I show you my bike I have a bike
in it in the parking lot and somebody
stole the seat they start like they just
you know they stole the seat they sewed
the tire and there's like three bikes
laying all around the city right now
it's so [ __ ] annoying
says beta that you got to thank Steve
for that there's no it's Eric with a K
everybody I know I hate that call me
Gregor great I like it what yeah it does
well they have to make it because they
have to make it so the tire can't be
stolen and they have to have that stupid
block on it you know they had that lock
you know so people can't ride it it
unless they pay but apparel is great for
the environment coming from caves coming
from caves
he's coming from caves I have it kill me
oh my god what's up yeah 15 miles your
[ __ ] legs get tight dude do they what
oh that's because you guys don't bike
that's portal is primed oh my god he's
in the temple oh [ __ ] a man come on
let's beat these guys oh oh that's right
I forgot about how Pikachu he passed out
right something like that
we threw up what cuz he was doing you
can't have him you can't have him do
regular sized people workouts man you
have to like adjust he's gotta make a
calendar yeah we should make a calendar
calendar I think that way if it was if
it was WB Civil War so coke would
obviously be Captain America because he
do she I'm the leader yeah for sure he's
he's the holy God what terrible person
would I be I guess yeah we got your mom
is there a fat superhero yeah hey Turner
[ __ ]
we'll invite [ __ ] I'm going in
oh man it needs to be like dirty
I'd be a [ __ ] yeah I'm trying I'm
trying to think what Marvel character
would he be it's even hard to make him
up no I know I know who Craig is Craig
is that guy he's that guy from Wakanda
but he lives in the in the mountains
he's the guy in the mountain he's at
Mountain King Mountain Kingdom like he
just comes down every now and then you
know a talk [ __ ] he's that guy I have to
trim this sucker once a week there's so
many heroes and I don't fit in any of
them oh my god people just love sending
messages so they could see their name on
the screen is so [ __ ] annoying if it
could be anyone Craig would probably be
the blob the gifted on foxes I'm sure
somebody already said that on Griffins
good one the hi oh god mustache rides I
mean if you're with me you're gonna get
you know it's gonna happen mustache
rides oh [ __ ] we're playing okay we're
playing a different game I got to change
my weapons curse you guys see that oh
yeah I gotta get my other hand cannon
destiny app is great for this do you buy
anything I bought a sweatshirt yeah if
you guys if you guys aren't out late
dude it's only on two like the 12th of
March checkout Museum of toys buy a
bleep obvious plan a stretchy
[Music]
he [ __ ] speaks in like [ __ ]
tongues he starts forgetting at a speak
I know somebody you know somebody who a
chatter so stupid yeah what kind of
question is that Allender they said
Pikachu Pikachu would be on on February
the shortest month but he has to be we
have to take that picture of him in a
bunk bed for sure though like a racecar
bunk bed wait what are you talking about
you already own it don't you and your
[ __ ] hoarder house you probably have
it probably is in this unpackage too is
still in the box
yes just in the box it's time God my
[ __ ] rocket didn't jumped off the
cliff like an [ __ ] oh my god I'm
terrible it's must be moderating okay
this guy by your you're gone forever
I don't know why people you know people
are such cowards man you know there on
the Internet
talking [ __ ] to people it's so crazy to
me AK [ __ ] come come to come come to
the Comedy Store cuz just easy to find
me [ __ ] in like you know I mean you
could like look at my schedule and find
me you know to me but I can't find you
you coward piece of [ __ ] I'm ready to
kill people
you know I couldn't be the Hulk because
I would have to be put away because I'd
be killing people all the time I'll be
turning into the Hulk for no reason just
had to Bank trying to make a deposit in
the tellers talking [ __ ] not just too
much longer than two months you see how
Pikachu just got to be involved talking
[ __ ] you know the ring too much now he
got some people he needs to be put in
check immediately
I'll jump shooting at my own team yeah
he's terrible right now
yeah yeah yeah ever since Pikachu chibi
he's gone crazy right now you know the
new cable cable network you know just
gonna slide yeah a little flash like
Wayne's World
oh man can staff get his ass what I'm
going back to my yeah exactly this is
like forgetting how to drive your car do
the wheels still in the same place did
it move to [ __ ] its earring wheel
alright have to go you're in timeout -
people think that I can't just block you
people are so stupid this disguise this
guy just talking [ __ ] yeah
yeah no I mean I'm not gonna blame the
whole chat just cuz there's a couple of
[ __ ] dudes whose moms dropped them
when they were young you know what I
mean oh my god dude I'm sucking a bag of
dicks right now at this game hey do you
must a fixed auto rifles or auto rifles
better now so you can use them in
crucible or they still suck
[Music]
no it's just hard you can't compete
against like hand cannons man slam in
the tunnel in the tunnel that's what
that's a show on pika TV there's a slam
into a tunnel what
but I'm coming with my shield follow
behind me my shield go get him they
can't get me oh man all right out of
shield
he's been warming up since 2016 these
people look at this idiot
[ __ ] let's make our glues his focus and
then he puts pictures of food we should
put your mom's [ __ ] on here cuz that's
just as fat with food too I mean how
about that get a picture that your mom's
[ __ ] like a hamburger
Henry Eriksson mama Eriksson I'm sure
she got a fat dirty [ __ ] that'll
distract me oh yeah no no no it's like a
it's like oh man what's that caught like
I don't you talking about
oh my god we're gonna figure of it down
a full pardon
yeah mama Eriksson I got a Fupa see you
talking [ __ ] once yeah once you put
pictures of your mom's Fupa
[ __ ] put that on there yeah yeah mama
Ericsson got everybody stuck yeah I blew
a moose knuckle no that's for dudes
that's a dude camel toe oh now you want
to kill that guy oh my god and get out
the way I think they buff slam but
Craig's probably gonna tell us for sure
that they they nerfed it yeah I remember
for the longest time they're like they
nerfed it man oh god I know we had to
hear that all the time it's terrible now
we can't use it
of course they [ __ ] all in the hoax
garbage like he needed a bob oh my god
it can't be this guy just killed me I
had a moose foot somebody's got a moose
foot what they really didn't buck and
cans
oh we [ __ ] that guy yeah they made it
where now you can't even use you can't
even use auto rifles against you that
you have to use like hand Canada fusion
rifles no but it's even worse now oh my
god that was terrible
why don't you play an apex
I can't believe Scientology is still a
thing right now I can't believe that's
still nice I'm gonna be in that next
mission impossible' you better like that
we don't we're kicking ass well actually
we're not we're almost kicking ass it's
close its close
why are these guys just hanging out oh
my god come on man Oh slam tomorrow I
got tone Bell tone Bell from the show
the fam comedian yet especial guys are
like tones good episode
I just got it a will fall to victory
that's pretty good that's a good first
time back okay
97 95 good first time bad y'all oh [ __ ]
I didn't do well I was switching weapons
guys your [ __ ] mouth on because
somebody asked who's worse between
between Craig and Griffin and I said
Griffin is undefeated against Craig and
Pikachu Pikachu also I had to beat his
little ass down to remember we played
talking [ __ ] let me get back to this
channel always in this chat thank you
I'm a beautiful soul Thank You Noah okay
it's not you guys spell my name right
Eri Kay Grif Craig was also working that
day when you're chewing cud in the
corner the [ __ ] are you you work in
[Laughter]
[ __ ] scream my brains out yeah thanks
to my directing tutelage I had to take
over because Craig Craig's mr. technical
we had Craig to spend all that time with
the [ __ ] GoPro the GoPro with the
[ __ ] drone remember that like that
that eight hours set up remember that
eight hours set up suppose I change my
name to Eric Diego Sanchez like that a
real name is that his real name has
tough fights he's a veteran bro not good
I'll never forget his fight with he
doesn't he's a gaming in cell it's
different he's a gaming and we're all in
Steve a beta Steve you're a beta you
don't play yeah next time we see Steve
I'm we're gonna get some Korean
barbecues when I'm missing your often
but [ __ ] Egypt they don't have Korean
barbecue where you are
mcdonnell's they got it they got a local
Chili's there's a good there's a good
Chili's now Koch every restaurant you go
to in your area do they have you do they
have your picture up you know you know
how you you're like - you like the local
hero don't you go to the donut shop
there's a picture I haven't been in one
eating contest thank you very much I
haven't been in any contest no I think
you need to talk us through the joke
because it was it was horrible
I'm father being husk I'm husky cute you
know to me that's the category
I'm husky cute you're in shape ugly okay
how about that new shirt in shape ugly
you try to make yourself ugly though
with your sweat suits and fanny packs so
I mean that's pretty ugly
I couldn't believe on Valentine's Day
just guy hat on
freakish slacks in this nice sweater do
you have those kind of clothes like
behind broken behind glass so you have
to break in case of emergency is that
[Laughter]
say you have a hot date you're like we
got to break the glass
beyond election be honest I knew I only
have one pair of jeans I buy so many
jeans and I would literally have jeans
for like all the different sizes yeah
you know after flooded and I was like I
need to spend money on all sweats hey
what is going on over here same outfit
speaking a same outfit in a cigarette
come on homie come on Oh is he saying
you got the expensive swept those black
jeans you got don't work $70 wait you're
wearing $70 sweatpants that seems like
that seems sexist can we please go back
and talk about Craig wearing black jeans
in the in [ __ ] and LA in California
like I look baby I look no you don't
look let's kill that notion right there
he'll be jelly don't be jelly craig has
never been like we would never cool and
Craig or not two words in like Alaska
you know I mean but other than that
we're getting our ass beat what's going
on come on they don't have Korean
barbecue or Internet
[Laughter]
did you like open the were you there
when they open the Golden Corral in your
area you had the big scissors he's sad
about it
Arthur be real be real how much have you
spent on come way clothing is that the
real name that's a terrible name folks
okay this guy killed himself like an
idiot haters gonna hate y'all I mean
this crazy the chat is just like they're
just going at each other like I don't
even they're not even watching me play
this is just a forum for [ __ ] talk it's
not come what's the name of it Vala
ranked up about what was I negative -
yes triple valor points right now
Tuesday wait let me look back and see
what I did I'm in see ya Arthur Arthur
like literally waits in line for [ __ ]
waves it's crazy don't
okay OC one of those guys is waiting for
like tennis shoes like that kind of
waves oh but I was at 0.69 I was better
than I kill more people think this [ __ ]
I got George I need to like count two
kills man I think that it's missing [ __ ]
wanted [ __ ] up at the end suddenly right
man
sunny right hey hey don't throw me into
the boat with you [ __ ] Jesus
Christ yeah Craig's on his own boat yeah
are you safe oh I I could say calm waves
we're not playing apex right now guys
for playing destiny just a destiny night
please that's the other day the other
day I played all of them guys the other
day I played fortnight call of duty and
apex I got one kill out of all the games
[Laughter]
Call of Duty I've got a shotgun kill in
the beginning I still like Call of Duty
better man
I like Call of Duty the best I mean apex
is fun it looks beautiful but something
about Call of Duty yeah right I agree
but I haven't got a winning Call of Duty
apex is easier to win you know but Call
of Duty I have it yeah I haven't got a
win in college I'm still searching for a
Call of Duty win I'm calling out in the
chat who can get me a win and call the
duty oh you got you got Kraig going
extra nasally right now dude Craig is
extra nasal right now no you don't need
to hook me [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] I'll
download because I'm honestly hey chat
listen she says you go download only
time Marcus it's mark this time
the only time I'm gonna play is when I
play Craig and then that'll be it I'm
never gonna play the game again so Craig
spent $60 to on the game he thinks he's
gonna be I'll tell you was he's so tired
every day I guess we'll have to wait
till MORTAL KOMBAT cuz then maybe you'll
find some no we play mortal I'll beat
you here's here's the difference Craig
Craig you play fighting games look if I
spent same time you do playing fighting
games I will be better than you it you
know that win this one I want my [ __ ]
money back for some of these fighting
games I still want my money back for
that stupid DC game what's that name of
that game injustice that was a waste of
$99 right there man you got you got to
be eleven-year-old boy to be good I
didn't know you know you know the store
sometimes it's confusing the Microsoft
Store is confusing man yeah you're like
what where's the regular [ __ ] I just
wanna spend $50 you know at most I don't
know what I'm supposed to look for [ __ ]
that guy
nice Thanks who the [ __ ] using a cold
hard I love cold heart that's a good
kind
especially you got the the catalyst on
it you get any catalyst yeah coke are
you still like oh my god I can't believe
I didn't shoot that sometimes I just
took the lead [ __ ]
so advantage showed advantage is yours I
like yeah I might have the edge on that
one I agree booyah booyah
everybody was all hyped up about made in
America
or whatever there cuz that one and then
it's just like no more it's like people
don't even watching it anymore
we're talking about it's only one season
I think because you can't do any more
like I think he's already given up the
ghost on that one yes the way like
another 40 years before he can trick
people again yeah cuz you got some
people good at this time especially that
one guy with the gun thing man oh my god
a guy he's gotta feel like an idiot how
a Sarah Palin - what Cheney signing love
the water torture waterboarding bottle
Oh hilarious right yeah my dick cheney's
actually got a good sense of humor about
himself killing everybody sure oh here
we go
[Laughter]
yeah that'll be on pika TV
[Laughter]
goddamnit oh my god that that that
turning staff thing that walks your
bullets dad is a pretty good that was
pretty good
your fooling behind I'm getting B I'm
getting B can we start to work together
yeah I can't like I said I was talking
about fortnight building [ __ ] and
fortnight is so stupid like that is the
dumbest part of the game I I can't stand
that that it just infuriates me when
people are building like the [ __ ] Taj
Mahal when you're trying to kill them
okay that's for all the kids
god dammit man that's [ __ ] creating
this game is so infuriating sometimes
what why did I kick I am so frustrated
with this game with this game yeah the
chats on I'm looking at it right now
what's your people talking nonsense what
you guys do the homies on the bottom you
guys are [ __ ] with all me I know
there you go guys
check in at the description and I should
be there bro what I don't know some guy
can't find the chat on your stream you
talking about us right there yeah he
just doesn't know how to work YouTube
like a decadent young noob he's such a
noob oh we're doing good right now are
you trying to get any battle works I'm
way of closing joke
what oh my god sometimes I'm really bad
at this but I had that guy in my sights
dude I just you have so advanced our
advantage is yours
[ __ ] [ __ ] she never error body everybody
in the club getting tipsy yes did did
you date so coke did you ever have club
clothes like you ever go to the club
dance with your buddies and stuff yeah
yeah it's the same outfit but the thing
is like I said confidence like I don't
need clothes
he's enough when you look like a piece
of [ __ ] you gotta follow Saturn
sometimes you know you got a you got a
just like a Backstreet Boys I'm totally
feeling
backstreet's back is that why you could
have been honey cash looked like that
Craig is getting this Johnny Cash rock
I'll have to look and see it day by day
getting B I switch it up sometimes or
dark-blue actually do you do you do you
crazy I want to see what Craig looks
like without the beard that's what I
want to see I want to see beardless
Craig it's just all cheeks [ __ ] out of
here art staff oh [ __ ] how a movie
oh come on man they're all by a nobody
oh my god oh my god this is so I'm
getting tatted see ya what's going on I
just gotta get to zones
keep the zones just keep the zones I'm
gonna stay here Abbi
if we grab the zones that's gonna be
points right there let's go let's go
okay grab a grab a anchor again oh we're
getting it okay there you go let's see
oh my god what happened
that's terrible lots of loose we still
have a we still have a what's only doing
right now look at these numbers [ __ ] is
all be doing in this [ __ ] let me see
okay yeah but I'm just talking about my
point three six KD that's all I'm
talking about
yeah I'm streaming games people don't
all streaming games I'm up here
streaming these games it's me somebody
messes me don't hate on my lovely thick
boy I'll defend his tenderness
[Laughter]
hey Michelle Obama said Eric you should
unblock Jefferson Quadra like that
Michelle Obama's advocating for
streamers to be honest mad cow I almost
didn't have like not real Hammer pants
but I husband yeah he was being I
pooh-poohed him he's out he was being a
dick listen if you if you say a funny
joke I'll laugh if it's funny but if
you're just being rude and need if it's
funny out loud if you if you give a good
crack on me on my okay but if you come
up with some [ __ ] get out of here
loser piece of [ __ ] that's how I feel
about you be funny here be funny that's
all I want be funny if you ain't funny
you getting blocked but he might be
right though Craig you probably yours
your legs comedic timing sometimes it's
just it's on point it does not exist
it's on point and I think pika TV is
taken up no it's not just like out of
nowhere
pika TV became a thing just like out of
nowhere like people like what's pika TV
can I find it is it on swing is that
YouTube TV I'd be so mad at life I know
that'd be the thing that'll be the thing
that makes us take off I'll apply it
pika TV guys there's our worst part team
verse 14 jerseys from olt
they have some good clothes and stuff
there oh [ __ ] I gotta go get my gamer GU
right now I forgot that I have some of
it I left it in the other I got my soy
sauce package of gamer goo oh my god
somebody somebody put somebody put a
hashtag pika life oh this is this is too
much now it's too much too much too much
it's too much - pika life
pika life what is pika life is that like
is that like you're a dwarf or like a
beak of life oh my god that's like a
reduction no that's a reality show
that's a reality show on pika TV pika
life sponsor yeah it's a hand goose I
don't know if you got sweaty hands we
got to a game or goop has anybody tried
does anybody masturbate it with it I'm
just curious is it you know just to try
yeah Pikachu we'll try it first
have you tried that just to check it out
oh my god oh did he ever
you get that fleshlight life just get
somebody give that you doesn't we have
to use it you know a drug dealer could
give you some crack and be like hey you
want to take this and you like I had to
take it he gave it to me you don't have
to use it they need to have it it's
disposable disposable ones you know cuz
I hate you know this is just too much
the cleanups terrible oh my god I can't
believe I didn't kill that guy why you
know the name and everything oh my god
these are the these are the kind of
sponsors that pika TV is gonna have you
know this is dishwasher safe if you're
putting your fleshlight in the
dishwasher you have problems okay yeah
can you imagine your cereal bowl what if
it doesn't wash it properly my cereal
bowl full of well I guess it's you
though it's not like you you know you're
not putting your friend's thing in it
you know it's your own stuff that's not
our sponsor
guy working for speaka team got TV or I
got one more game name you guys then I
gotta get off this are you talking about
we streamed a lot where we're like 75
minutes right now whoa yeah you're right
it might be this game after this game
I'm done I don't realize it I didn't
realize right cuz we're at 29 let's win
this though we gotta get this win
[Music]
what oh my god there's no getting away
in destiny like if somebody's shooting
at you you just have to turn and try to
kill him because if you try to run
it's just sure death I got my breath hi
my Wizards rebuke out well I mean you
don't you and your brother share pants
and stuff like that well that's what
caused it
no no no no no no you're using your
brother's your brother's shorts or your
pants that's all that is your brother's
shorts or your pants oh my god why can't
I feel anybody's
[Music]
I'll get off
shoot shoot this [ __ ] get him oh yeah
baby I just wrecked it right there with
my [ __ ] super and I got wrecked by
super I got him
he's hops on oh you shut the enemy down
oh I can't leave I escaped
what is that guy using what the hell is
Oh submachine gun all mine some machine
guns are still good I see some machine
guns got that good rate of fire one I
don't know what it's gonna do but that
new the new weapon to get for the
crucible on the updates the submachine
gun what is that is that that's a
submachine gun yeah that thing's [ __ ]
me up what happened we were just like in
the lead I don't want to hear yeah yeah
this guy stole my [ __ ] heavy
wow that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god that shield I haven't tried it
man I have to go into the other room
I'll try it next time we will do a whole
game or go streams Emmett [ __ ] why are
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys jumped on destiny do [ __ ] can
you believe it
I know we're on destiny like a bunch of
douche bags all he used oh man he used a
suppressor grenade on me that was
beautiful
that was a beautiful suppressor grenade
cat Golden Gun I forgot behind dude
relax
yeah here's like really what's going on
yeah yeah we could make a pika TV red
zone yeah
welcome to red zoning on pika TV brought
to you by gamer good today we have on
the show erich koch sponsored by Golden
Corral get your free Golden Corral fanny
pack and sweat bottoms with every
purchase
that's how you hide your nuggets right
defeat Jesus Christ all right guys just
another great stream here on Griffin
gaming we did it let's check these
numbers let's get these last minute
numbers when everybody that still wants
to uh
waitwait home looks like a code you can
get your joke in everybody that wants to
continue to watch the stream switch over
to worst fire team switch over to worst
fire team and continue to watch the
stream on worst fire team pikas playing
so you can see how little he is pika
looks like a unshelled Ninja Turtle so
when you uh like like it's at night you
can't unsee it's like at night when they
take the shell off I sent it to the
cleaners
so the go look at worst fire team to
watch the stream continue thank you